I just want to say something okay so
that's a mistake and I took it down
right away here's the thing well no it
was up for like 17 hours nope yes it was
Howard no it was is that your whole name
yes it is when people are mad at me how
was it up for 17 hours Alex hey he's
Alex said yes I slept for through
through it so it was right before I went
to bed yeah I saw this picture where did
you see that picture
um so so on Tick Tock I sometimes go
like weird or I'll look up like weird or
gross oh I just looked that up you know
wait wait wait wait hold on backtrack
you went to Google you typed weird or
gross yeah and you somehow found a way
to a prolapse weakness I didn't know
that oh you didn't know what it was no
oh what did you think it was really I
thought it was gross I thought it was a
wet cake stuck to Somebody's Ass no red
shirt yeah why do you know what are you
serious Alex is that true
randomly I'm gonna put up this gross
picture and I'm gonna go is this covet
related